It's been a great year for television, but
unfortunately we can't say the same for many
of our favorite, dearly departed characters.
That's why we're paying tribute to all the
TV characters who unexpectedly left us this
year.
Be careful if you're not caught up on all
your favorite shows - from This is Us and
Walking Dead to Jessica Jones and even New
Girl.
There are some major, major spoilers ahead.
Millions of eager fans of NBC's smash hit
This Is Us knew that Pearson patriarch Jack
was going to die, but they weren't quite sure
how.
On February 4, the show finally revealed exactly
how Jack passed away.
In a flashback sequence set in 1998, we see
the family's slow cooker short out, sparking
a fire that quickly engulfs the Pearson home.
Jack wakes up in the middle of the night,
smells smoke, and turns into Hero Dad, getting
his family out of the house with a bedsheet
rope.
Then he goes back into the burning house to
save Louie, the family dog.
He's taken to the hospital to attend to minor
burns, and all seems well.
Until:
"Your husband went into cardiac arrest.
It was catastrophic and I'm afraid we've lost
him."
Carl Grimes grew up on TV.
The son of Walking Dead protagonist Rick Grimes,
Carl had been with the series since episode
one back in 2010.
Along the way, he endures tragedies and setbacks,
including the death of his mother during childbirth,
the loss of an eye, and various acts of evil
by the show's villains.
Keeping Carl alive and safe is the reason
Rick never completely crumbles, and Carl keeps
human decency alive.
Unfortunately, his luck comes to an end when
a zombie finally takes a bite out of Carl.
It's a death sentence, but not an immediate
one, giving Carl time to say goodbye.
He hangs out with his little sister Judith,
writes farewell letters, and then shoots himself
before he can go full walker.
Carl wasn't the only Walking Dead character
whose death caught us by surprise - Simon
was Negan's loyal, selfless, and nasty second-in-command.
What did he get for his constant devotion
to the evil leader of the Saviors?
Violently choked to death by his former boss.
His death isn't completely out of the blue,
though...
Simon had been pretty brashly making some
overtures to take over the Sanctuary.
Negan knows about it for a while, but rather
than kill Simon right away, he gives Simon
a few chances to prove himself or make it
right.
Ultimately though, Simon's luck runs out when
Negan challenges him to a fight - with fatal
consequences for the loser.
"You got saviors killed and then you ran away
like a coward.
You got shown up one too many times."
NCIS wound down its 15th season with a heavily
promoted plot: The departure of original character
Abby.
NCIS viewers worried that this news spelled
doom for the fan-favorite character.
It definitely didn't look good for Abby when
an episode ended with Abby and co-worker Clayton
Reeves seemingly shot by a mugger.
Resolving that cliffhanger ending, next week's
episode found Ducky sympathizing with another
coroner about the agony of performing an autopsy
on a former colleague.
Had Abby died from a gunshot?
[Sad music]
Surprise!
She hadn't.
Instead it was Reeves who had died, having
selflessly stepped in front of Abby to take
the bullet.
Despite surviving an attack by a serial killer
called the Black Hood earlier in the season,
Midge doesn't quite manage to make it through
the rest of Riverdale's second season alive.
Her fate is sealed when she's cast in Riverdale
High's production of the musical version of
Stephen King's Carrie.
When the curtain on the show rises, audiences
- and half the town of Riverdale - see a gruesome
sight.
Midge, brutally stabbed, with creepy messages
written in blood on the wall around her.
Midge may be gone, but she's definitely not
forgotten.
"The vixens and I vow that we will not rest
until those responsible for the murder of
our sister is rightly punished.”
Modern Family isn't the ratings juggernaut
it once was, and its tenth season may be one
of its last.
To bring back some of the viewers that have
tuned out over the years, the show pulled
a little publicity stunt before the season
began, promising that a "significant character"
would die an episode to come.
Fans and reporters speculated about who would
be the one to kick the bucket - but no one
expected it to be DeDe, Jay's first wife and
Mitchell and Claire's mother.
Deaths on Gotham are frequent, but the victims
are usually just underlings, stooges, or random
bystanders.
Shockingly, two major characters meet their
end in the show's fourth season finale.
Butch managed to cheat death once when he
was brought back to life in a toxic swamp,
but he's ultimately killed by the Penguin
as revenge for Butch's earlier murder of Penguin's
mother.
Classic Batman villain Ra's al Ghul also bites
the big one in the season finale.
After Barbara turns down the baddie's offer
to leave Gotham, she stabs him in the chest
with the assistance of Bruce Wayne.
Will Simpson was a vital character in the
first season of Jessica Jones; first a cop
controlled by Kilgrave, then a love interest
for Trish Walker, and then, finally, an unstable
killer addicted to super-steroid-esque pills.
When season 2 starts up, Simpson is stalking
Trish.
He corners her and gets shot in the leg - at
which point he warns Trish that she's in danger.
A useful warning, but delivered a bit late,
since he's mysteriously killed minutes after
he delivers his warning."
Kimmy's tough-as-nails landlord Lillian found
love in the third season of Unbreakable Kimmy
Schmidt with Artie Goodman, the owner of a
Whole Foods-like grocery chain called Big
Naturals.
Nothing lasts forever, though.
At the beginning of Season 4, viewers learn
that Artie died on their vacation, and Lillian
was entrusted to spread his ashes at the site
of his summer camp in Manhattan, which had
turned into an exclusive club.
Barred from entering the club, Lillian is
able to give Artie the final resting place
he asked for, along with some closure for
herself: She sells two plastic baggies full
of Artie's cremated remains to a bunch of
finance-bros who clearly think those ashes
are something a little more party-friendly.
"This is the most fun I've had disposing of
a body since…
Well, just don't make me choose!"
If Scandal had to end, so would one of its
main characters.
Somebody had to pay for seven seasons' worth
of political machinations, backstabbing, extramarital
affairs, politicking, terrorism, and murder.
That person wound up being Attorney General
David Rosen.
In the penultimate episode, Washington, D.C.
fixer Olivia Pope tells the public about the
existence of the secretive B613 operation,
hoping that the revelation would somehow stop
sneaky, power-crazed Vice President Cyrus.
Unfortunately, that leads the increasingly
unhinged Cyrus to respond by poisoning Rosen
with a deadly cocktail.
"David Rosen, you… are in my way.
No hard feelings."
The second season finale of the rebooted X-Files
killed off a lot of longtime characters.
One of the season's main arcs concerns Cigarette
Smoking Man's plans to unleash a deadly virus.
To pull it off, he manipulated Scully's shape-shifting
son William - along with FBI Assistant Director
Walter Skinner and Agent Monica Reyes - into
helping him execute it.
Smoking Man also happened to be William's
biological father - he was the one who'd drugged
and medically impregnated Scully nearly two
decades ago.
William, wishing to be free of all this evil,
finally confronts his dad on a dock while
using his powers to disguise himself as Mulder.
Smoking Man shoots William-as-Mulder in the
head, right before the real Mulder arrives
to shoot Smoking Man and kick him into the
water.
The deaths don't stop there; Skinner shoots
Agent Reyes, before getting run over by a
car himself.
Luckily, it isn't all doom and gloom - William
seems to have survived.
Fox's New Girl isn't so new anymore, and it
came to the end of its seven-season run with
a handful of episodes to wrap up all of its
loose ends and give each of its characters
a proper send-off.
Alas, a finale usually means somebody has
to die.
And in this show's case, that somebody would
be Ferguson, the beloved smush-faced cat belonging
to Winston.
While viewers were saved the not-very-sitcom-friendly
images and emotional turmoil of watching a
pet die, New Girl devoted an episode to Winston's
over-the-top grieving process, which involves
a motorcade to an elaborate memorial service
conducted in the Jewish tradition.
We'll mourn you until we join you, Ferguson.
When the Tim Allen sitcom Last Man Standing
returned to Fox more than a year after ABC
canceled it, producers made a few changes.
One of the biggest changes was that Bud Baxter,
portrayed by veteran character actor and Oscar
nominee Robert Forster, wouldn't be back at
all… because in the new season, Bud is dead.
Forster shows up here and there on the ABC
version of the show, but producers used the
network switch to send his character to the
great beyond.
Luckily, Bud still got the opportunity to
appear one last time as a ghostly vision for
closure on some unresolved issues.
"I tell my kids I love them all the time.
I don't think I ever remember you saying that."
In May 2018, Clayne Crawford was shockingly
fired from Fox's TV version of Lethal Weapon.
Apparently, in his two seasons of work on
the show as loose-cannon cop Martin Riggs,
Crawford made life difficult on the set for
many people, notably co-star Damon Wayans.
Prior to the third-season renewal, fans learned
that Crawford would be replaced by Seann William
Scott, who would play a new partner to Wayans'
Roger Murtaugh.
That ramped up speculation as to how Lethal
Weapon would explain Crawford's sudden absence.
The show addressed the issue with its third-season
premiere, which found Riggs dying from a gunshot
wound he sustained in the second season cliffhanger.
Of course, the body count of TV characters
doesn't end there...and, shocker, a few more
come from that zombie show where lots of people
die all the time.
Here are some more familiar faces who went
off to that DVR in the sky...
Nick Clark - Fear the Walking Dead
Tobin - The Walking Dead
Spencer - American Housewife
Madison - Fear the Walking Dead
Gregory - The Walking Dead